this is a great story to not only
communicate to you things going on in
the real world but also to talk about
how narratives are created and framed by
corporate media
so listen basically support for
impeaching Donald Trump went up when
news of the Ukraine fiasco first broke
hitting about 46 47 percent and then
throughout everything that we've seen
happen publicly related to Ukraine and
Trump so far
if support for impeachment has crept up
to 50 percent 52 percent fifty five
percent depending on which poll you look
at now that by itself is big news this
is a lot more impeachment support than
there was for Richard Nixon early in
Watergate it's not normal when it comes
to previous presidents Obama Bush as
much as Obama and Bush were hated by the
right and left respectively you didn't
have more than half the country saying
that the president should be impeached
when it was Obama and Bush so now we
have a new poll the poll happens to be
from Fox News of all places and it says
indeed 54% of the country wants Donald
Trump impeached now you might notice
that I'm leaving out a piece of
information here and I did it on purpose
for the for the purposes of our story
today I did this deliberately
when I say 54% of the country wants
Trump impeached if you are a media
literate individual if you're a savvy
thinker you should be saying does david
mean 54% want trump impeached by the
house or is david saying 54% want trump
impeached and removed via a conviction
in the senate that is the right question
to be asking and that is exactly the
game that is being played with these
numbers the game that's being played in
lots of corporate media is that they
aren't specifying it clearly whether by
impeachment people understand that to
mean or are meaning to say that they
want the house to impeach and a trial in
the senate whose outcome could be one
thing or the other thing or are people
saying when they say they want to
impeach we want trump convicted and
removed by the senate in this poll 54%
want trump impeached 50% want trump
impeached
and removed meaning that there is 4% in
there that want Trump impeached in the
house but not necessarily removed by the
Senate so this is already one game that
can be played you can talk about support
is up versus support is down but by not
specifying whether you're talking about
impeachment only or impeachment and
removal you can kind of pick whichever
result is closer to suiting your view in
the narrative you want to craft this is
how you simultaneously had some network
saying impeachment hearings have
destroyed support for Trump impeachment
and you had other media outlets saying
support for impeachment is up since the
hearings have started if you want to say
support for impeachment is growing you
choose a poll that shows it even if it's
just for articles of impeachment and not
removal or vice versa I think that you
understand the other game that is being
played is the momentum game after
hearing started right Wow
the hearings have really deflated the
impeachment movement and then at the
other time you have some saying wow the
hearings are really growing support for
Trump impeachment now how could both be
true just look at different polls so the
real story is not the two to three point
swings and impeachment support because
that's all that we're seeing tons of
people don't even know what's going on
or at least aren't paying attention
daily so the real story here is roughly
half the country wants Trump impeached
and removed the numbers going up and
down to three points that's really not a
big deal
what's not normal is that half the
country wants the president impeached
and removed but most importantly if you
look at the internals of the polls
there's a big polling gap in favor of
impeachment if I only tell you 50% wants
Trump removed you might assume oh so 50%
does not want from promote its dead even
it's an even split wrong lots of people
respond that they don't know or they
aren't sure so in the Fox News poll 50%
want him impeached and removed 4% want
him just impeached and 41% say don't
impeach that means it is not 50/50 it is
a plus 13 the people that want an
impeachment versus the people that do
not that
huge that's what really matters do not
be tricked by crafty reporting into
taking your eye off of the ball which is
that half the country wants Trump
removed and there is a +13 gap of people
that want impeachment over people that
do not it won't change whether it
happens of course but don't fall for the
games that the corporate media is
playing around impeachment polls